so I guess some people think I don't do
romantic comedies I beg to differ my
friend's life as we know it although I
think they should have called it life as
we knew it I think that would have made
more sense so life as we know it's a
romantic comedy starring Josh Duhamel a
carefree guy who rides his motorcycle
and gets all the chicks otherwise known
as mr. awesome and Katherine Heigl a
smart goal-oriented hot chick who's in
her mid to late 20s who's kind of a pain
but she's still cool ish but officially
speaking those they do not exist I mean
the Roswell landing you know maybe who
knows but a cool hot goal-oriented hot
chick in her mid-20s no not at all
except for my viewers of course and
don't worry ladies if you want to jump
on this bandwagon you too can subscribe
so their mutual friends died in a car
wreck and in their will they dubbed them
the new parents of their child and yeah
those two cannot stand each other like
at all but in these movies you know that
always leads to love now I personally
thought that Katherine Heigl and Josh
Duhamel were really good together I mean
they were kind of cute together they
were believable maybe because they
fought a lot I don't know but they were
I mean they're polar opposites she's all
like oh we're a family now and he's like
oh family
I mean I'm not gonna lie it was a total
guilty pleasure watching the three of
them katherine heigl josh duhamel and
the baby become some sort of family
throughout the movie I'm just sitting
there going that's nice I mean not me
personally other people you know I I
don't I mean I'm Jeremy you know I don't
fall for that
Who am I kidding it was nice and funny
the movie was funny it has really funny
moments however I do have a pregnant
friend and this movie taught me that
when that pregnant friend gives birth I
am snatching that kid and I am taking
that kid grocery shopping with me at the
22 and desperate I love the produce
department because a guy with a baby in
public I mean that's like catnip to
women they just can't help it did I say
desperate I meant classy 22 in classy
classy always classy like my subscribers
I mean it's not like this movies like an
original romantic comedy but I don't
think the words romantic comedy and
original can ever coincide in the same
sentence like ever been again I can't
think of a lot of romantic comedies that
involve parents who died in a car wreck
and pass their child on to polar
opposites who can't stand each other but
will form a relationship throughout the
movie will oh maybe I think that's the
closest thing I can think of they had a
baby right and two gay guys something
like that willows awesome by the way but
at a point in this movie you know
exactly how it's gonna end like verbatim
there's no denying it so as a single guy
I enjoyed this movie and that I know I
shouldn't kind of way so the rating I
would give it is I would watch this
movie if I knew my friends would never
find out yeah that's nice too but what I
I wasn't watching that and there it is a
romantic comedy review from me to you
and if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more than click
right here to see more
[Music]